hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast at phenotypic antibiotic
susceptibility testing of positive blood
cultures presented by Margie Morgan she
is a professor of pathology and
Laboratory Medicine and also the
scientific director of microbiology at
cedars-sinai medical attention
I am Marjory tourist of labrys and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web summon are presented by
lab routes and sponsored by accelerate
Diagnostics for more information about
our sponsors visit accelerate
Diagnostics comm before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower lap of the presentation window and
type your questions into the box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as you have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support question at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
the problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Marjorie and Morgan I will now turn the
presentation over to her
[Music]
and thank you for having me
today I'm going to take a little bit
different tact and I'm going to walk
because some people might be bored by
the laboratory so I'm going to walk
around and keep you all awake okay all
right so I'm going to talk about the
actual laboratory participation in all
of this and we're going to be doing the
actual testing in the lab blood cultures
yes it's kind of complicated we've been
working on blood cultures for what forty
years trying to make them more perfect
and we've gone from limiting
contamination which can be extremely
important when you move toward molecular
testing and rapid phenotypic testing
because if you have mixed blood cultures
it makes the whole situation a lot more
difficult so we're going to limit
contamination we're working on getting
the adequate amount of volume and our
blood cultures because that's very very
important and then let's move on we need
to get into the laboratory and into the
instrument as fast as we can we need to
pull the cultures when they become
positive in our laboratory currently
we're doing gram stain's on positives
we're then performing molecular testing
as you can see and communicating with
our pharmacists about the results from
our rapid molecular ID and resistance
marker testing but then that's when we
slowed down and dr. grind and all of our
crew they become disappointed with us
because our past methods have always
been to do very carefully make sure the
identification was appropriate and do
susceptibility testing using automated
susceptibility systems and even though
maybe we only had one pathogen it could
take up to 40 hours so that's where we
were kind of letting down our
stewardship team
so with this optimal for our patient
care well our passage on identification
really was quite rapid we had
identification by a molecular
identification methods we also had multi
toss that provided rapid methods but
sometimes we got into situations such as
shown here where we had a poly microbial
blood culture where the resistance
marker was detected the the ecole the
intro bacter cloaca was detected by a
resistance marker resistance in ID meth
but it did not detect the Klebsiella
pneumoniae that came out about 18 hours
later
so it was like surprise yes we thought
and perhaps it only had an interval back
to cloaca but now we also have a
Klebsiella pneumoniae so that is one of
the limitations that dr. Greene was
talking about with some of these
testings is it's very good for Manik
Manik Ron microbial calls but sometimes
you do get into situations using the
best of these resistance and ID marker
methods in mixed cultures the other
thing if it's optimal for patient care
let's talk about the resistance markers
themselves okay
these methods are very good but they
have limitations the molecular marker or
resistance marker detection from a
positive blood culture comes out in one
to two hours that's quite remarkable
we're doing things so much more rapidly
than we used to but it can vary in its
ability to properly guide therapy
choices particularly we found in our
institution with the gram neg
detecting a resistance gene does not
necessarily mean that it is being
expressed and as dr. grind discussed
some of the resistance that we are
seeing in our institution and I'm sure
you as well are not detected by these
resistance markers that are on these
panels sausage is the amp see in the
problems with porn and a flux so we're
doing all of these wonderful molecular
resistance testing but really I hate to
say it sometimes the physicians are not
very comfortable with some of the
results as he said through our
stewardship interventions and they are
really waiting for us for two or three
more days to perform susceptibilities so
even though we instituted all of this
new thing and we thought we were doing
the newest cutting-edge work perhaps we
really weren't supplying what everybody
really needed this is just an example of
one of the discrepancies that we had
just recently with our resistance marker
testing versus our full phenotypic
susceptibility you can see on the left
hand side that our resistance marker
detected
FPL no espl on a Klebsiella pneumoniae
but if you look at the susceptibility
result that we had up to 36 hours later
it would truly was an ESP L now what
problems do you get into the laboratory
with doing things like this over time
with pre Seng percentages well of course
there's the patient care issues and
we're greatly concerned with that in the
laboratory but also we're greatly
concerned that some physicians just
never forget if you have one of these
and so it makes it a lot more difficult
on our stewardship group to go back with
more interventions to try to de-escalate
antimicrobials because perhaps a
physician they're talking to was the one
that actually had this patient that that
dis occurred with and so I think that's
one of the shortcomings that we're
seeing in the laboratory was just doing
the molecular resistance testing so is
there a need for doing rapid
susceptibilities
well there's is for phenotypic
antimicrobial susceptibility results are
often necessary for a very good
optimisation of patient therapy the
molecular platform can detect the
presence of known resistance genes but
as we shown in our laboratory no
molecular method can determine whether
an isolate is susceptible to something
and oftentimes that's the question that
they get with their interventions thank
you you're trying to explain to me why
that CTX - M means now what's it
susceptible to are you sure this is what
it's going to be susceptible to and so
that is perhaps not being provided when
we're just doing the resistance markers
of course and of course we're seeing
lots of new organisms coming through our
Medical Center it's an amazing some of
the organisms that we've seen over the
last six months or so and phenotypic
results are certainly more helpful with
this new emerging resistance in the
gram-negative bacilli so let's talk
about rapid susceptibility results and
possibly what the accelerate Fino system
can offer now there's been methods to
speed up ASD testing over time some very
creative methods be
done in laboratories but the first
fda-cleared rapid susceptibility method
was when the FDA granted clearance to
the accelerate diagnostic fee no test
blood culture kit and that's what's
shown here this is the cartridge that's
used for testing
it's truly a unique and divergent
susceptibility method and I will explain
to that to you in the next few slides
and it provides rapid final
susceptibility testing in seven hours
compared to what we've been doing for 36
to 40 hours overtime so on the left-hand
side with what our current method was
you can see it's many multiple steps we
thought we were doing cutting-edge the
best of microbiology we could and for
the time yes we were but by going
through the left and all those multiple
multiple steps it took us up to 40 hours
to get a susceptibility with using the
accelerate system we go to this on the
right hand side you can see there's less
steps in the process and it's so it's
much more improved efficiency type of
testing system and we can provide a
susceptibility within seven total hours
after the inoculation into the system so
we really think we're not only doing a
more rapid job for our physicians and
for our stewardship pharmacists and
individuals but we're also more
efficient in the laboratory in the way
that we are testing so this is the
accelerate Fino system some of you may
be quite familiar with it perhaps some
of you not over on the left-hand side on
the top is the system it can go one to
four modules I believe it can even go up
to eight modules per PC and you can see
the testing modules and there's also a
touch screen monitor that comes with the
system the module which is in the middle
if you opened up that module and took a
look inside you can see it's a very
complicated and very sophisticated
instrument and this provides an
automated pipetting robot with a digital
camera in a custom microscope
so we're getting into some what's so
unique and divergent about this system
as you can probably tell I've been in
microbiology a lot of years and I've
been doing susceptibility testing since
the early 1970s and forever we've relied
on is it turbid if they're in
spectrophotometry readings so this is
what's truly divergent about this
technology we're moving away from just
turbidity and we're actually making use
of newer digital camera technology and
the custom microscopes to be able to
look at the organisms themselves and
that's what's unique the kit you can see
it's a plastic over on the left hand
side that blue circular thing is the
flow channel cassette the white is the
reagent cartridge and that little vial
there is where you put the blood
specimen so you have your positive blood
culture that comes out of your automated
blood culture system it is then aliquot
it into that small little plastic vial
and insert it into the cartridge and put
into the system within the system it's
going to lyse the RBC's it's going to
filter out all the RBC remnants and
other particulate matter in dispersement
and it's going to immobilize the
bacteria onto a grid after immobilized
the first thing that happens is the
identification of the organism that is
present in that positive blood culture
okay and it does that by FISH probes
that takes approximately an hour in 20
minutes the next step of course is the
performance of the m.i.c i'm sorry if
i'm standing in front of you i will come
over here for a while the next thing is
the performance of the m.i.c and that's
what i think is its really self
fascinating and different and we're
going to talk about that on the next
slide the susceptibility is done not by
turbo metric methods that i've been
doing since the 1970s it's done by
Morpho kinetic cellular analysis in
studying these organisms it's a totally
different way of looking if an organism
is resistant to an antimicrobial starts
with tracking growth rates
in in establishing a growth curve and
then it will look at the division rate
distribution of the organism so instead
of getting turbidity you get very very
sophisticated looks and snapshots of
what the organism is actually doing as
it grows in the presence of those animal
ovals so this is just a very very
different unique approach to
susceptibility testing you can see this
one is a resistant organism it just
continues to grow and beautifully
repopulate and then on the right hand
side you can see that the e.coli is
susceptible and it is dying off over
time from being exposed to the
ceftazidime
so that's what makes this system so
unique that's what the cartridge where
the cartridge is put into the testing
module and this is where the cartridge
is contains the blood sample and it's
put into the instrument there's one
cartridge for all testing whether you
have a grande positive or gram-negative
isolate it goes into the same cartridge
and put into the instrument this would
be the organisms that would be
identified on if it were a gram positive
organism
identified by the fish probe and these
are the yeast the albicans and glabrata
and these are the antimicrobials that
are tested on the test cartridge if you
have a gram positive organisms which is
identified if you have a gram negative
it'll identify one of these eight
organisms by the fish probe and these
are the antimicrobials which will be
tested for the gram negatives okay so
does this work well yes
one would assume that it works it
cleared FDA so of course it is is past
the the ultimate test and his has very
good correlation with broth dilution
methods which it was tested against so
in this is clinical trial data at the
top and listed over here on the right
hand side there's 1800 positive blood
cultures it was originally studied the
results for identification were
available in one hour
20 minutes you can see all of the
organisms that are identified on this
panel in each of the sensitivities and
specificities overall in the clinical
trial the sensitivity was around the
97.2%
in the specificity 99.4% we have a much
less experience we have not done 1,800
samples yet in our experience we've done
85 positive blood cultures so far
results were available for ID in 1 hour
and 20 minutes as found in the clinical
trial our overall sensitivities been
about 97.6%
we've had two Klebsiella that were not
detected and our overall specificity was
ninety eight point eight with a
confusion of one culture between inner
all vector and Klebsiella these are the
susceptibility results from the clinical
trial you can see once again a very very
high essential agreement a categorical
agreement for the susceptibility results
once again 1,800 positive samples with
an overall ei of 95.6%
and 95.4% for specificity the FDA met
demands greater than 90 percent for
acceptance of a system into the market
yes this might not be the end-all of all
antimicrobials that you might want
tested on some of your organisms you
might have on occasion have to do some
offline testing and I'm sure that
accelerate will be doing their best over
time to add some of these newer
antimicrobials to the test panel but for
right now these are the ones that are
currently available this is our
susceptibility results at cedars-sinai
we met very favorably with the clinical
trial and we have not had any issues
with formulary antimicrobials failing on
the accelerate system
okay how about monarch microbial versus
polymicrobial calls I was talking
earlier that there was an issue
sometimes with our molecular systems and
not being able to tell us if there was a
poly microbial issue okay so what about
monochrome monochrome monitor microbial
calls we're very fortunate that we have
a very low contamination rate in our
blood cultures and so most of our blood
cultures not all but most are mono
microbial and so that makes this system
extremely useful for us okay so for a
mono microbial sample it is positive for
only one pathogen of course the positive
predictive value is ninety-nine point
six percent and if you have a with a
Gram stain interpretation if ninety
seven point eight if you're bypassing
Gram stain and just doing direct
inoculation we've had very few failures
and there were very few failures in the
clinical trial of mono microbial calls
the only thing that you could get into
problems with if the numbers of
organisms in the blood culture itself is
so low that it's not being able to be
detected by the system
how about polymicrobial capabilities
that was one of the issue that we saw
with our molecular resistance markers is
they were not able to tell us most of
the time if there were more than one
organism that's one of the unique
features of the pheno system which i
think is very useful even if it's not
able to identify a second organism or so
in the blood culture it will give you an
alert that there is a second organism
present so you will never get into the
situation like I had in that first slide
okay so you can ID up to three ID
targets on the panel but if it's a poly
microbial with on-and-off panel it will
report the ID target organism and they
will alert you that there is another
organism present on the panel and that
can help very much with our stewardship
efforts it will do the m.i.c on the
predominant organism if there's not an
organism and predominance it will not
provide you with the susceptor
ability but you may provide you with
organism identification and then you
would have to do offline susceptibility
testing if the two organisms that are
present are so close in the way they're
growing and in their division it will
not supply you with a susceptibility as
I say we've been lucky in our experience
at Cedars is we have mostly mono
microbial blood cultures and so that has
not been a big issue but every Medical
Center will differ in that this is the
accelerate sino report as you can see on
the right hand side here it's easy to
read it can be on the screen or you can
print the report it's an intuitive
computer system very easy to use and it
has customizable m.i.c interpretation
for fda clsi or you cast breakpoints it
has export rules for interpretation it
provides
assay analysis as you can see here
there's notes that provide you
information for interpretation of the
report just like the current ast systems
do there's it's certainly interface able
and the people that accelerate will you
will help you and provide assistance in
interfacing this instrument what's
getting started
we met with stewardship of course they
decided that the best and most clinical
value use of this test would be for the
gram-negative rods I think I've made it
clear to you that we've had some
failures with such things a seller rate
will offer a verification protocol it's
a about a twenty twenty-five page
document that walks you through the
verification process I can't tell you
how much that helps a microbiology
laboratory get started they also have
developed and individualized quality
control template for microbiology
laboratories so we can establish weekly
QC I think one of the most fascinating
and wonderful things about the system is
the QC it's a frozen little snap-in
module no more 0.5 McFarland's
no more organisms all over everywhere
that you have to accumulate every week
in order to do QC it's a very very
unique and very
a time-saving way to do QC and if you
are gonna do an L is connectivity
accellerate will assist you and you
certainly need to allow time for that it
always seems like the microbiology
laboratory moves a little bit faster
than does those computer people okay
finally why use the accelerate system
well of course it supplies rapid
phenotypic susceptibility to improve
patient care of course it is accurate
the FDA and all of the clinical trials
have proven that we have found that
there's limited limited clinical utility
of gram negative resistance markers and
that we get good results from our grande
positives but accelerate it really does
improve our therapy and stewardship
interactions with our gram negatives you
can resist replace your resistance
marker testing by actually doing rapid
final susceptibility testing and in our
high-risk patients where we're starting
to see more unusual organisms we really
think this will be very very useful in
our stewardship team was in great
acceptance and they're very happy that
we're moving in this direction and they
said that their interventions will be
more definitive with a final
susceptibility that includes susceptible
antibiotics and not just resistant
markers and it's worst at 7 hour wait to
get that information and with that
Jonathan and I will entertain any
questions that you might have about the
system thank you
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Morgan for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button what answers many of your
questions as you have time for let's get
started our first question is what
advice do you have for a lab director to
gain alignment from her or his
organizational leadership to move
forward with implementation of new
diagnostic equipment well that's a very
interesting question I guess the first
thing I would say that you need to do
your homework is the diagnostic
equipment really going to offer
something of value to your Hospital into
your stewardship group to your group of
physicians and patients that will be
using the information I would go to the
literature and see if there's any
literature on the topic if I'm attending
a meeting I would make sure to drop by
the booth it is it's actually selling
that equipment see if I can see it
firsthand it always helps to use to talk
to users if the equipment is out in the
field yet so will the results from the
sensor it be useful in your institution
and particularly with your own patient
population that would be very important
is it possibly worth the increased cost
that the laboratory may have to bear
sometimes there will be offset savings
to the hospital but after all we're
going to have to bear the brunt of the
load in the laboratory so I'm going to
have to provide justification for why we
should do so collaboration can be very
important stewardship committee members
pharmacists infection control and ID
physicians it's going to be a
collaborative effort and they can help
me provide necessary data to
administrative leaders I think the most
important thing is for years we've been
talking about things but I think we're
to a point now where we really have to
provide data it's not just words on how
this equipment can really help us with
either antibiotic optimization patient
days in the hospital
or help save lives or lower see
difference we really need to provide
data to prove that this could be true
also we need to provide potential budget
issues for the laboratory but also how
this could save money for the hospital
perhaps show literature if available how
this has worked out in other
institutions also do you have staff
ready and able that you can do this
technology are they technically able to
do the verification studies and all the
patient testing so if we have it to have
make an argument to administration for
increasing staff that can be very very
difficult so I need to show data that
the equipment can be used for existing
staff of course as that is true so
hopefully with all this information and
collaborating with others we can make a
valid business plan and get an
instrument like this implemented even in
my hospital Cedar sinai thank you for
that answer our next question is if you
are in an institution that did not
currently have resistance marker testing
would utilize accelerates an IgM system
for gram positive blood cultures and
what other circumstances would you
recommend using this device for all
positive blood cultures that's a very
interesting question um if you lack
resistance marker testing in your own
institution I think one should certainly
look at the use of the accelerate for
both gram positive and negative
infections we did not do it in that way
because we were actively using another
system for gram positive markers and in
our institution the gram-positive
markers had been used for years and were
used successfully however in some
institutions that might not be the case
with resistance marker testing and
studies have indicated that clinicians
are often unwilling to de-escalate to
optimal antimicrobial therapy until
antibiotic susceptibility is actually
obtained so I think there's certain
a understanding that it would be good to
move to accelerate for both
gram-positive and gram-negative
applications there was a paper recently
published in IDs a publication for a
community hospital I think it was the
University Health of Augusta Georgia and
in this situation they showed case
studies we're having the pheno test
blood culture results really did help
treat patients more than 50 hours faster
than their previous methods and it was
demonstrated that having this fast AST
versus just ID alone for the gram
positive bacteria had a very positive
outcome in clinical outcomes of the
patient and really helped in optimizing
therapy so i think one could make the
argument in the lack of any type of
resistance testing or available
information that it could be very very
useful to use the accelerate for both
gram positive and grip negative
infections as being said you do need to
to look at the gram positive panel and
realize there are potential some small
but potential issues such as speciation
of the streptococcus i with the gram
positive panel that moved has moved some
of us into just using it for the gram
negative application but i still think
that it has a very strong use for the
organisms that do exist on the panel so
i can see that institutions moving into
using it for both gram positive and gram
negative thank you our next question is
what have you observed about clinicians
willingness to adjust therapy based on
phenotypic m.i.c as compared to
resistance marking or test result well
as i said in my talk we're mostly using
and the accelerate system currently at
Cedars for the positive patient blood
cultures that have gram negative
organisms so in our institution we went
that direction because the clinicians
felt more comfortable using they did
feel comfortable using the gram positive
resist
marker information but did not feel
comfortable using it for a gram-negative
bacilli our grandpa's knee resistant
markers have been pretty reliable for
the mrs a the van a and van b but they
have not been as helpful for the
gram-negative infections and we've had
failures with our gram-negative markers
on the current system that we're using
such as the CTX - em the vehm the imp
and so forth it wasn't necessarily a
failure of these tests they just didn't
have the type of resistance marker or a
capability of detecting the resistance
that we're currently seen in our
gram-negative rods we're sorry to see
some emerging resistance of amp c pouran
and a flux alterations so it is really
becoming very clear in our institution
that there was a lack of confidence in
just using resistance markers and that
they really wanted to have a
susceptibility to be moving forward with
changing antimicrobial therapy and
that's where the accelerator has become
so important and so helpful is we can
provide that rapid final susceptibility
on our gram-negative rods and can move
away from the use of the resistance
markers for the gram-negative bacilli
thank you our next question is please
explain how the mono microvolt called
provides clinicians with a confidence to
de-escalate antimicrobial therapy what
is the significance with this
well the mono microbial call is cited
under the note on the report that you
get from after the completion of the
accelerate run is actually on the report
that you observe on the computer or when
you print out the results the the mono
microbial call gives you information
that that positive blood culture that
you just ran on the system is positive
for only one pathogen the accuracy of
this claim is in numerous studies
and it was excited in my report that I
just gave my talk that I just gave that
it's 99.6% positive predictive value
with a Gram stain interpretation and
97.8%
positive predictive value without a gram
stain so the ducts of the matter is that
this call can help the stewardship
pharmacists with their interventions to
assist with antimicrobial optimisation
and can help the physician to be more
confident that there's not another
organism that's lurking in that culture
that they can trust the results that
we've produced so the Mun of microbial
call is a very very useful thing to have
available to us in the laboratory Thank
You dr. Morgan for the answer do you
have any final comments well I would
just say from our experience in using
the accelerate system it has really been
a very useful to our stewardship
committee in moving forward with
optimization of therapy and as I've said
in some of the answers to these
questions as well in my talk it's been
very useful particularly for the
gram-negative bacilli that we're seeing
currently in our patient population
unfortunately we're starting to see
emerging resistance at the amp C and
pauran and E flex alterations and having
a rapid phenotypic susceptibility has
really proven to be very very helpful I
would like to once again thank dr.
Morgan Morgan for her presentation I
would also like to thank accelerate
Diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing in February of 2018
you'll receive an email from laberd's
letting you know in this podcast will be
available for replay please check out
announcements with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye